you had three sons yeah and y-your son
Noah is very much into fashion yeah
now does he ever pick out outfits for
you to wear he does he designs he draws
outfits and then when I do fittings yeah
he's very he's very talented and but but
he's still sick so and I do fittings
like I did one recently and I had this
really beautiful yellow dress line he
kept draping it in a way where he was
like if we do it like this it looks like
a diaper that's not what we're going for
but maybe next time so he he's really
into fashion and he's the one like
sometimes he'll he'll dress himself and
he likes to wear dresses sometimes and
he'll and I send him to a really liberal
like hippy school but even even there
here in California he still has little
boys going like boys don't wear dresses
or boys don't wear pink and so we're
going through that now where I'm trying
to teach him to be confident no matter
what I don't know he finally he had
stopped wearing dresses for a while he
just wore one two days ago to school and
he came home and I was like how was it
did any of the friends at school have
anything to say and he was like well all
the boys laughed when I came in but he's
like but I don't care I love dresses
[Applause]
[Music]